so remember there's not different arts
so you have to use the same kazushi
pattern so
i have the front inward kazushi pattern
this one
and i have the back outward because you
should
okay so the first one is
he's gonna get me in the headlock and
you'll see his energy is going that way
he goes in boom and so you can see
go back do it on your own whoa
here's that here's the front position
pad
so i feed that energy he goes around
secure
keep going around boom
get your base
base out all four corners
so one blend
all four corners
then
secure this arms the problem are
this arm because i don't want him
punching
so i have a couple options i can get it
here this way on the back side some
people are so wide
then take this one or take both
this arm's not doing anything it's just
wasting his energy
but this arm i i don't want him i don't
want to be holding this
he gets that boom okay
so in the movement he goes i release
accept catch that arm and let him go
into the kazushi pattern and we're gonna
stop here all four
corners knees and hands oh let's try
so he goes i yield to it
face clear secure my base even more
then i can move this hand here
here on this jaw hinge push if my arm's
long enough if my arm's not long enough
come inside
and take this at an angle so i'm go
i'm not pulling straight into this i'm
going to go at an angle
this way then you have all your escape
so
you can do your arm bar
so relax yield
base check over
if i can reach here if i can't hear
boom
so
okay okay so uh let's say yes
so if i'm going to do for example
hook you hold
his body moves into that with this step
and then this the outward backward
opens itself up so the same thing
happens here
so as he goes he'll step again to re hit
his mouth you see he'll feel me
healed he will he's go
he won't feel this you see so he feels
the yield
and he takes his face again you're not
going to get
but he will open himself up to this one
now okay
so you're trying for the first one is
the first one
and you're just gonna go
and do the same
so really if you just let him do his
thing i'm coming here he does his thing
and i put my leg inside you can kick
that leg out too
and you're in the same technique
okay so now leave the technique out and
just work the uh
the concept of yielding so he's gonna go
i'm yielding i'll just go
do the first one again i go
i yield
i'm just extending his energy we go go
ahead
and i don't have to think about it he's
doing it
i feel his energy
and that's the same thing on the other
one so
go slow so you can see i'm starting to
do that one
he realizes it's gone you see that's
what he's gonna do
so he goes i go he feels that
and you'll feel like ah too late
you want to feel when the energy changes
again
oh my god can you go this
not after the fact it's not a leverage
technique
and it goes it goes again
and then i'm going to do a leverage
i'm going to feel his energy he goes
really i'm not doing anything his base
changed and the energy leaks out
and he goes
he does the first one without that step
a yield
[Music]
okay let's let the technique go